я б просто хотів запитати як хтось
все-таки інформував населення окрім
нашої поліції або що не так сказав
людина яка там присутня ця
рожевий він роздавав може бути
Батьківщина роздавала може де ти
чи то десь я знаходжуся
нідерландах а нісенітниця ти роздаєш тут
листівки.
ви можете засовувати малюнки дам
Нідерланди в крові у нас світі за умову
на вертикальному українські політики то
напевно нам треба з'ясовувати стосунки у
києві в Україні
нехай приїде в Україну неможливо не
знає є такий сайт МВС України там
буваєш рошу особливі знаки знаходяться в
рот шубу янукович мене поставив у розшук
і я в розшуку знаходжу з часів януковича
kia приїжджай не ховайся нісенітниця ти
ховаєшся від свого боку я не розумію
ти винен ти чи три справді
винен просто пройди альбе вирішити
питання навалюватися сенат я довго шукають
не по правді на здачу роти не лізла
приїдь та доведи у своїй країні
можна по-різному ставитися до партії
батьківщина але коли юлію тимошенка
арештували вона нікуди не втекла сьогодні
ми зв'язка
порошенка приїхати і за розшуку навіть що
за політик чи вибач за слово то
якесь чого він боїться